bevor dieses Video startet muss ich eine
wichtige Sache machen
Laktase und der Tag gehört dir hallo
Leute hier ist wieder eure malwanne und
willkommen zu diesem neuen Test Video
heute werde ich alle Osterhasen testen
die ist so im Supermarkt gibt man kann
ja schon mittlerweile sagen jede große
bekannte Süßigkeiten Firma produziert
mittlerweile seinen eigenen Osterhasen
so auch zum Beispiel Smarties wer ist
auf diese Idee gekommen wer dachte sich
der Kopf wird ein riesen Smarties und
dann wachsen da halt noch Ohren und den
Körper raus dieses Video kommt ja auch
an Ostern also frohe Ostern an alle die
ist feiern gönnt euch den freien Tag
zwei freie Tage die man dafür bekommen
und wir fangen jetzt an ich habe so ein
bisschen übertrieben mit der Auswahl ja
ich habe einfach jeden mitgenommen den
ich so gesehen habe dass ich irgendwann
gemerkt habe wie viele Osterhasen ich
eigentlich ja da war es aber auch schon
zu spät und der Grund warum ich
überhaupt auf dieses Testvideo gekommen
bin ist die Werbung für den neuen
Yogurette Osterhasen hey Hase Ostern
wird pink damals in meiner Kindheit gab
es nur ganz normale Schoko Phasen und
was ist mittlerweile alles auf dem Markt
gibt verrückt ist die Frage da ist ja so
viel Osterhasen sind weil ich sie
eigentlich nur Köpfen aber ich will auch
sehen wie sie drin einfach aussehen ist
dass ich meine so ziehen wir die
Schönheiten hier mal aus euch
ein Osterhase mit Windpocken ist ein
bisschen hart jetzt ne Kinder guckt mal
kurz weg
oh das riecht wirklich nach Yogurette
irgendwie ist es halt und jetzt
boah
weiße Schokolade immer eine gute Idee
aber mit diesen erdbeer-quiz wow was
hast du gekostet 2,49 € für den
Yogurette Hasen ich will noch mehr
beißen ich sollte es aber nicht tun
Bewertung 9 von 10 Punkten die
Geschmackspalette muss natürlich auch
erklärt werden soll ich euch mal was
sagen ich habe richtige Adventskalender
auspackt Video Vibes Team und ich haben
dieses Set hier noch mal aufgebaut weil
ich nicht irgendwie immer im Wohnzimmer
drehen möchte das ist so ein bisschen
privater Raum und ja schreibt mir gerne
wie ihr das hier findet als nächstes
nehmen wir diesen Osterhasen den
langohrhasen Leo von
arco/hussel ich wusste nicht dass Akku
und Hussel mittlerweile zusammengehören
das ist der besonderste Hase den ich
jemals gesehen habe denn er hat so coole
Ohren und alle Hasen sehen eigentlich
immer gleich aus nur nicht der hier ja
gut der kostet auch 8,99 €, ne mir passt
schon zu schade den zu probieren heute
Ostern ist könnt ihr ja mal gerne
schreiben welchen haben ihr heute
gefunden habt der fühlt sich an wie
Plastik wann hat das eigentlich
angefangen dass man den Osterhasen so
komische looks gibt macht ihn doch
einfach so wie er aussehen soll oder
also ich finde es ist so Leoparden Hase
wer hat da Bock drauf
[Applaus]
diese Schokolade mit ganz fein und
besonders tatsächlich schmeckt die
Schokolade eins zu eins wie in
Schokolade der kommt als nächstes das
Rohr abgeschnitten der Ferrero Küsschen
Osterhase hier habe ich tatsächlich
keinen Preis weil ich den einfach so
noch an einem anderen Tag gekauft habe
aber cute ist Ferrero Küsschen Brownies
ich weiß nicht ob das sein muss ich
meine du hast den Ferrero Küsschen Hase
dann lass ihn doch einfach nach Ferrero
Küsschen schmecken oder also das mit dem
Brownie verstehe ich halt nicht warum
muss man da dann noch irgendwas dazu
machen ich finde ihn aber auch von der
Optik bin ich ein sehr schön sehr süß
der hat das Yogurette Prinzip mit
kleinen Stückchen ich denke mal der
Sophie ungefähr abschneiden
also hier könnt ihr diese Schokolade
ganz gut sehen ich verstehe es nicht
also es gab halt keinen normalen Ferrero
Küsschen Hasen aber warum dann so ein
Brownies Teil daraus machen ja es ist
ganz lecker ich würde sagen Brownies
Style weil das sind so knusperkugeln
drin also Knusper Style habe den
Osterhase der wirklich auch noch Ferrero
Küsschen schmeckt besser gefallen ich
bewerte doch schon wieder die ganze Zeit
nicht mehr bekommen ähm 7 Punkte
Küsschen bekommt von mir aussieht
eigentlich macht die Bewertung von 0 bis
5 viel mehr sind dann muss man sich
nicht so komisch und Punkte noch
überlegen ich warte mal ich mache jetzt
weiter mit der Bewertung von 0 bis 5 Uhr
ich merke schon welche meine favorite
sind hier der Kinder Überraschung
Osterhase ein Osterhase und einer Kinder
Überraschung drin
ja es fand ich cool ich frag mich wie
Kinderschokolade schmeckt nach zum Glück
habe ich den Hasen gekostet
das ist finde ich immer sehr wichtig ne
wenn man den Osterhasen aufmacht und der
Osterhase an sich noch hübsch aussieht
und nicht nur so eine glatte Form ist
nur die Alufolie macht nicht so viel
Spaß candle Jenner Style da ist es hm
Kinderschokolade
Kinderschokolade ist für mich eine 55
Kinderschokolade ist so lecker das ist
unser Kinderüberraschung großer
Überraschung drin
wertloses Plastik was man nach einem Tag
irgendwo in die Ecke schmeißt das Leben
ja ich habe so ein Hasen mit App
verbunden hier ist ein Ring dazu und
dann muss ich hier dieses Ding Teil
zusammenstellen und dann wirft man
und das ist ein tolles Spiel
ja das Ding ist weg was hast du denn
gekostet mein lieber 2,49
Spielzeug kostet genauso viel
Gramm hast du 75 Gramm Yogurette 75g
beim nächsten Hasen bin ich wirklich
gespannt der Mozart Hase von den
Mozartkugeln Vollmilch Schokolade ich
bin in der Hoffnung dass er schmeckt wie
eine Mozartkugel 3,99 € du schmeckst
jetzt mal besser gut ähm wir operieren
einmal die Ohren ab da steht sogar
Wolfgang Amadeus MOZ
schmeckt schon nach leckerer Mutter
Schokolade 3,99 dann will ich über den
Yogurette Hasen der bekommt von mir drei
von fünf Punkten wegen dem Preis bei wem
wir aber uns preis-leistungsmäßig sicher
sein können der gute favorina Lidl
Osterhase als Kind wollte ich immer
solche Osterhasen haben ich weiß nicht
warum aber nur dass sie da ein bisschen
die Ohren und Augen und sonst was noch
extra mit anderer Schokolade einfärben
das war für mich wirklich als Kind der
beste Osterhase den man bekommen kann
200 Gramm Schokolade das sind zwei ganze
Tafel Schokolade für
2,29 € meine Damen und Herren nein doch
und wir haben sogar ein Fairtrade Symbol
muss ich noch mehr sagen er soll jetzt
schmecken oh toll guck mal beim
Abschneiden ist weiß vom Ohr ne wenn ich
zusammen essen
Moment das schmeckt jetzt hier nicht wie
Lindt aber sehr lecker fünf von fünf ich
weiß das wäre ein bisschen
verschwenderisch gewesen aber ich habe
bei Lidl ein Osterhasen gesehen der war
so groß ungelogen und dann habe ich ihn
gesehen und dachte mir Herr dann gehe
ich die nächste Woche kaufen wenn ich
für mein Video einkaufen gehe dann bin
ich losgefahren und dann hatte kein Lidl
mehr den also ich habe da wirklich ich
bin dazu drei Mädels Gefahren wer durch
Berlin und keiner hatte mehr diesen
großen Osterhasen ich bin ich traurig
ich hatte sogar extra so eine
Luftpolsterfolie drumherum damit er bloß
nicht kaputt geht das so ein wertvoller
großer toller Hase war seit meinem
letzten Video als ich original vs du
Produkte verglichen habe ist mir erst
mal so richtig der Schleier von den
Augen gefallen ne Markenprodukte das
heißt das muss nix heißen wo ich aber
ganz hohe Erwartung habe ist dieser
Ferrero Rocher Osterhase ich weiß nicht
was das bedeutet dass er von Roche ist
hoffe dass eine Kugel drin hört sich
nicht so an
2,99 € für 100 Gramm der hat keine er
ist ein Gesamt
[Applaus]
das war ich nicht so sieht die
Schokolade aus
bitte auch ein Ferrero Küsschen sein
schaut mal wie viele Nüsse da drin sind
das ist einfach wie eine Kugel wow
lecker ist ja schon echt weit oben ne ne
das ist schon vier von fünf der nächsten
müssen wir eigentlich nicht ausprobieren
weil ich habe das Gefühl wie ein
lindhase schmeckt weiß ich schon ganz
genau ich hatte hier aber einen kleinen
Denkfehler ich dachte der goldene Hase
ist kein Hase und dann habe ich den
gesehen und dachte mir dieser Art zum
Glück haben sie ja noch ein richtigen
Hasen weil ich will wirklich nur
Osterhasen nehmen
und irgendwann mal war ich dann noch mal
im Supermarkt habe diesen lindhasen
gesehen und dachte mir
diesen Hasen habe ich definitiv gekauft
und mich darüber lustig zu machen wie
abgrundtief hässlich ich den finde diese
ganze hello Serie von Lindt ist ja diese
neue moderne also neue ist jetzt auch
nicht aber diese moderne Richtung so was
sind gar nicht machen muss obwohl dieses
heute Karamell Schokoladen und so die
sind ganz lecker wenn mir Timo morgens
diesen Hasen hinstellen würde ich wäre
natürlich sehr dankbar aber ich würde
mir nur denken warum kriege ich nicht
den goldenen
das ist schön Schokolade lecker ich
brauch definitiv noch einen Laktase
Tablette obwohl ich glaube mehr der
sogar besser geschmeckt
4,39 €. meine sind auch 140 Gramm 2,29 €
200 Gramm irgendwo reicht's dann auch am
Anfang habe ich mich schon lustig über
ihn gemacht und jetzt kommt der der
Smart
3,79 € für 175 Gramm was soll ich zum
Design sagen irgendwie sieht der witzig
aus Ende bis sie da haben sich Monate
lang Leute Gedanken darüber gemacht wie
der nächste Osterhase aussehen soll nur
damit ich jetzt hier sitze und die judge
ich liebe mein Leben etwa ein
smarties-spender
aber witzig was machen die schmecken gar
nicht so gut
ich habe das Gefühl man bezahlt hier
halt hauptsächlich dafür 3,79 €, das ist
aber ganz schön viel Schokolade die wird
ihm eine drei von fünf geben ich habe
euch dieses Jahr schon öfter erzählt
dass ich 30 werde ich bin ein bisschen
aufgeregt ein bisschen nervös aber es
ist auch eine Zeit dass ich mich langsam
an neue Produkte annähe und etwas für
alte Menschen ausprobiere
englische Art ich hab das früher ab und
zu mal gegessen aber ich es ehrlich auch
nur bei Timos Eltern wenn Sie das da
stehen haben und nicht einfach Bock auf
was Süßes habe und nichts anderes da ist
boah ich weiß ja nicht ne das hast Du
gekostet
39 mensch das ist ja noch günstig hör
mal auf es riecht nach After Eight aber
es ist keine Creme drin
nein nein das Design ist wunderschön ich
finde das haben sie ganz toll gemacht
und netter gelöst als Smarties aber
Minze und Schokolade das das schmeckt
als ob man sich gerade die Zähne geputzt
hat und sich denkt ach komm das eine
Stück Schokolade macht es aber kein
Karies doch mach das hör auf damit
jetzt fällt mir auf jetzt machen wir die
Nestle Party zu Ende jetzt gibt's noch
den kitkatrie von Nestlé super habe das
nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt
schmeckt ganz gut
das ist mir eine Herzensangelegenheit
der vegane lindhase ich habe
den noch glaube ich hatte
[Musik]
den frohe Weihnachtsmann es ist im
Endeffekt das gleiche boah habt ihr ein
süßes Gesicht dazu geschlossene Augen
ich freue mich dass du mich isst und ich
finde die vegane Schokolade von Lindt
eigentlich schon richtig gut auch gerade
wenn sie so ein bisschen special
Schokolade draus machen mit Caramel
Popcorn ich glaube das sind die Sorten
die nicht kennen
also wenn ich so den ganzen Tag noch
nicht süßes hatte und mich dann auf die
Couch setzte und so ein Stückchen vegane
schokolade zum Beispiel auch von Linde
esse dann denke ich mir so offen toll es
ist vegan das ist schon mal klasse es
ist laktosefrei dadurch was für mich
noch mal besser ist aber jetzt wo ich
diese ganzen Osterhasen probiert habe
und jetzt dieses vegane lundstück
probieren das ist halt nicht zu
vergleichen ne das schmeckt halt einfach
anders 3,99 € für 80g ich verstehe aber
auch z.B nicht warum muss der jetzt grün
sein wie geht es langsam tierisch auf
den Keks das vegane Produkte immer als
gesund grün dargestellt werden muss ja
gar nicht stimmt also nur weil man etwas
veganes ist heißt es ja nicht dass es
gleich total natürlich und gesund ist
ich sage nicht das ist schlecht das ist
toll wenn man sich vegan ernährt gerade
fürs Tierwohl und für die Nachhaltigkeit
aber dazu braucht es eine Menge Zutaten
aufgefallen deswegen mochte ich die
Tunnel Produkte auch so weil sie so
neutral wirkt als aller aller letztes
kommt für mich der Osterhase der für
mich wirklich der absolute Regie unter
den Schoko Osterhasen zu Ostern ist ja
Milka Alpenmilch Hase und ich habe sogar
als kleinen Twist den Oreo weiße
Schokolade mega Hasen wieder mal mit
einem ganz tollen verrückten Outfit
super warum muss er so eine hässliche
Sonnenbrille tragen was ist das wo in
welcher Marketingabteilung haben setzen
die sich zusammen und denken so ja wir
ziehen den komisch an ne let's go und
mein Akku ist alle das heißt ich sag
jetzt schon mal tschüss es hat mich
gefreut das war mega toll mit euch
schaltet auch wieder das nächste Mal ein
wenn ich irgendeinen anderen scheiß
ausprobiert wird ich hoffe euer Leben
ist schön und frohe Ostern wow weißt du
Schokolade Oreo das Gefühl Oreo hat mega
gerettet so viele Produkte die sind
zusammen haben